if there is now quite a serious the
situation is deteriorated because there
is such animosity and an anger and a
mutual desire to hurt the other it's
it's I mean Greece's performance is
greatly deteriorated so doing what they
are doing they are hurting themselves
and Europe also if it pushes Greece out
of the euro or you would hurt itself is
it a 50-50 possibility I would say yes
it has deteriorated it doesn't need to
be there because the basis for for
bundling through finding a compromise is
there but it would require probably the
four months of negotiations and points
by points and then you don't need to
write down that debt now you can just
keep on pushing it back almost
indefinitely and just keeping the
primary surplus at let's say between one
and a half percent and three percent but
in the meantime there will be no primary
surplus because the Greece is going down
the drain
mr. can I also ask you about the UK
elections because it's a tough time for
Europe actually in the next six months
how worried are you about the UK
elections I think that just as Scotland
in the end didn't pathways with Britain
I think that Britain will also find some
way to stay in in the European and
actually the threat from Russia
ought to be a powerful inducement for
Britain and Europe to stick together